what up everybody i'm out here in
calabasas at the world famous fake boys
studios the greatest studio in all of
calabasas much better than kanye's
studio where he's recording donda much
better in that studio where kim
kardashian made that video with ray j
the greatest studio in all of calabasas
and we're about to record flagrant too
thank you mr shaw you're a legend
[Music]
what's up everybody and welcome to
flagrat2 podcast we're recording this
because of hurricane henry
out of
the illustrious thick boy studios in
calabasas california i'm sitting here
with the one and only the thick boy
himself we got brendan shaw in the
[ __ ] building
okay thank you so much for taking us in
we are hurricane victims you are right
now we are stranded
refugees
[Laughter]
oh we out here bro listen you know show
up is just about the
sound off them i get the one who get
three
shots yeah
you got the moderna yeah and that was
the one okay good good but you don't
think that it should be mandatory no and
you would do it you wouldn't what you
want to do man yeah yeah yeah
if you're in shape and [ __ ] what about
going out to dinner like don't you want
to go out to dinner and sometimes they
say you got to get backs to do that's
why you're allowed to do that yeah but
you're allowed yeah you're allowed to do
that yeah yeah yeah yeah okay let me ask
you this question um are you on that
[ __ ] test right now
no what's up dogs
i'm juicy this is natural or this is all
natural i don't know i've been in the
weight room since fourth night
fourth grade this is different this is
hard work dedication this is [ __ ]
different i think you're on that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
because i didn't notice mark got swole
so mark when we first picked him up this
was a couple years ago i guess he was a
skinny kid but he always had the super
fatty like he's like
he's got a tailbone
[Laughter]
both have asses yeah still got the
tailpiece on it he does he does but theo
is like built for it
uh i don't know if he's just weird feels
is like
a raptor yeah yeah it looks weird it's
not weird it almost looks fake but his
back smokes he's got a mullet and it
kind of goes into it yeah
but so what happened is he was always
kind of like thick in the legs and then
he started working out for like a year
straight recently recently he's and he's
[ __ ] he's he's on creatine is that
pds that's pretty much bds don't you
think that's legal you can't talk you
can get creatine
but you can use
them swole and and they didn't motivate
you [ __ ] when one of them
it wasn't even one of the circle ones it
was one of the magenta colors
[Laughter]
we started making fun of him for it and
then he started to make us feel bad he
goes well you have to start somewhere
guys
all i'm saying is i think that you're
both on something bro yeah
i think you're on something
i expect that though because that's what
people you know oh so you're throwing up
500 pounds i woke up like this
i don't know what to tell you bro you
got pecs and [ __ ] now yeah back in the
day listen i've always been big since
i've been remember i thought you were
mexican i don't even think you're
mexican no more
i don't know but you worked out of it
[Laughter]
and you used to be stupid
bro used to be super mexican
what is he what is he now he's big boy
you were thick he used to be yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
so the comedy stores woke now or what
you know they're doing they're you know
what happened bro what happened yeah you
know they're just uh the the guys aren't
there so it's like you know the whole
vaccination thing but still a great club
like i'm at la jolla common store uh
this weekend yeah yeah yeah but it's
different down there yeah it's also
different the way you're describing it
now
i don't know what it's talking about
[Laughter]
the secret sausage show
guys
thank you so much for listening sean
you're the [ __ ] man thank you fighter
and the kid i mean tell them everywhere
that they can they know who you are but
tell everybody where they can watch this
i'm in la jolla next week check them
it's coming out tomorrow so it's tuesday
tuesday so yeah check out thursday
friday saturday la jolla comedy store
um and then the big one san antonio bud
light event center september 24th 24th
whoa whoa whoa whoa
we love san antonio san juan is a great
fight in texas it's unfucking real have
you stayed at that hotel emma no
i i wasn't involved with the uh san
antonio
best hotel in america so that's where
you won't airbnb that's what your hotel
even then as much as i love that hotel i
might do airbnb just because you guys
you know seven people hotel and was a
five star will you guys just stay in
those cages or
how does it work
what if he's bringing a girl home you
gotta give him the big cage then i get
him
yo so check him out at san antonio where
are you where can they get tickets
uh think boy.com or fatkz.com
done make sure you check it out i love
you man you're the man thank you so much
and thank you so much for what you've
done for me man a lot of people don't
know that they should know that thank
you so much i really appreciate it
god bless it's been player 2 peace
here's the new studio on a wide guys for
the channel
we got headmaster dumbledore nick davis
behind the controls he set all this [ __ ]
up
jen just clapped in the background for
him
because his knee hurts
this [ __ ]
daddy's [ __ ]
touch yeah
what's up do you say back tap off
what up man
oh and then you can do then you can pick
see so you go it's absolutely whichever
one you want the thing to be so you know
so like double tap what do you want the
double tap to be then what do you want
the triple tap to be okay
yeah
i mixed my flavors with my nickname
shout out all right dude all right i get
it i converted stevia
don't add to it i want to forget you
that you said that yeah
yeah baby
um
this would be hilarious dude that's a
funny sketch
all right uh he's like hey hi guys you
may know me as short round uh
hey that guy got some work in the 80s so
no no he's not the he's the old guy in
big trouble he didn't grow up in
victoria
oh my god are you that's not his dad
oh so any any asian is an age they're
related that's what you're saying
in the face jackie might as well just
say hey was that chin or come on
undoubtedly
i'm not even joking what happened to his
career
oh cause he was a kid actor yeah
he did all the work like when he was a
kid he was in the indiana jones yeah he
was short round he looks like a nerdy
nerd like a real nerdy jacket yeah
what's his name uh something quan yeah
jonathan
yeah jonathan kikwan yeah he was great
hey you guys mind if i grab a liquid
death death or a thing yeah i'm not i
don't care i'm
or they get emancipated from their
parents
we're trying to get like will smith kid
did that at 15. what's his name again
jayden jaden
yeah 15 he was like yeah i got you did
that
people got emancipated at 14 years old
oh wow
his dad was 100 at that point
he was kind of on his own
whatever you want to do man i'm around
for another seven days yeah that was
like a trailer
yeah if i start lifting it like he was
i think i could beat him in that
challenge he's been beating me
we stuck enemas in our butts the other
day
okay
oh he he won
i had to smell his poo
yeah what did you guys put a tarp down
no we were we were like on the ground
like crisscrossed like this and we were
squeezing enemas in our butts and
whoever what whoever pooped
that's a good question but bubba you
don't have to do that they do that no
they do that on asian tv
that's some asian tv [ __ ] man wow it is
man it is
no no no that's our idea no
no that's our idea what are you talking
no that's our thing
no no it's an old thing it's an old
thing yeah and you don't know
they copied you yeah they look like
asian game shows
no no we really got naked like we're all
diapers no we weren't indicted well they
do it even different they have like a
tarp down
there's like a tarp down and they have
to stand there and then they end up just
don't show us anyways yeah nobody
watches it and then poop comes out yeah
on the ground
yeah griffin is leaving the building
guys that's a wrap on cats
catch them in new york
caroline
2nd through the 4th i'll see you there
what's up y'all we're
over 50 000 and we've been slacking we
need to fly out another fan we're
actually flying somebody out last time
the fan drove from orange county we got
remember la traffics it was a beast so
don't hate but this time we're really
flying a fan out to work out with me and
the boys at zoo culture all you got to
do we're going to randomly pick a fan
the boys are going to pick you guys out
all you gotta do is submit your email to
here
and we'll pick one of you and then you
get you and a friend get flown out stay
in a hotel and then you get to work out
with us and jump in and watch one of the
podcasts one of the many shows that i do
that's it so submit right here
and we'll find you